what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to the river roundup our
weekly series where we cover all the
news and rumors that you may have missed
over the course of the week and as you
guys have noticed we're doing this on
sunday why because sunday's our new day
for the rumor roundup truth to tell
fridays was kind of a cool time to do it
but one it's not the end of the week and
two trailers would drop which would
basically prevent us from being able to
make an episode of the rumor roundup
because we had to make a video on the
trailer instead but who the hell
releases trailers or announces anything
on a sunday so we are doing the rumor
roundup from this day going forward
having said that we are going to talk
about the video game announcements all
kinds of cool stuff but before we do
let's open up with something that's not
enormously important but it's really
cool nonetheless so as most of you guys
know marvel movies marvel tv shows have
largely been snuffed when it comes to
awards right just kind of looked over
blown over and nobody really seems to
take them all that seriously which is
strange because they are quite literally
the highest grossing franchise in the
history of hollywood maybe it's one of
those things where people say that
movies are art but if they do
how do you explain frankenfish because
that's not art to anybody however one
division recently changed that for those
of you guys who are unaware one division
recently won the award the emmy award
for outstanding production design for a
narrative half an hour long this is cool
because now the marvel cinematic
universe officially has awards under its
belt and these things usually tend to
snowball that when one part of a
franchise wins an award usually things
start following suit now one division
was a particularly good show honestly i
think loki was better and so i wouldn't
be surprised if loki started winning
awards and then in turn depending on
what kind of movies they released later
on down the line sheng chi i can almost
guarantee is going to win some kind of
an award and if it doesn't i'll be
absolutely flabbergasted i'm by no means
calling it i'm just saying i feel like
it should but this provides a bit of
legitimacy to the marvel cinematic
universe where people are finally
recognizing that this franchise really
is as awesome as everybody's making it
out to be as if the money didn't speak
for itself but moving on to our next
topic marvel has announced four release
dates for unnamed projects these release
dates are as follows february 16th may
3rd july 26th and november 8th
all 2024. now there have been different
responses to these release dates the
kind of idea of what these release dates
might represent in sense of the movies
that will be there we will make videos
here on geek culture explain addressing
this and what our picks are for the
movies that are going to be coming out
or possibly even tv shows that are going
to be coming out during this point in
time however the talk of the town is
ryan reynolds response to all of this
so ryan riddle's response was obviously
joking but he was throwing out all kinds
of stuff fantastic one weekend at blind
owls jen genie
nick fury road it was just all these
goofy responses but the real cool thing
here is what's actually kind of going on
behind the scenes have you guys noticed
recently that before the fox acquisition
ryan reynolds was almost never talkative
about the marvel cinematic universe
almost never talked about it almost
never addressed it never really seemed
to have a whole lot to do with it since
the fox acquisition his conversations
about the mcu have actually ramped up to
the point that he's talking about them
more and more often has anybody noticed
that i don't know if it means anything
i'd like to believe it means something
i'd like to believe that when it gets to
the point where he's talking about the
mcu every day is because this movie's
coming out that weekend i have no idea
that's the case but it would be cool
but it is really exciting to see that
ryan reynolds is kind of maintaining
that jokey nature that we're familiar
with from the deadpool franchise and
just kind of continuing on in his tweets
and how he relates to what's going on
with the marvel cinematic universe
disney all that kind of stuff the movie
releases plus i gotta be honest with you
guys man ryan reynolds is just a bright
ray of sunshine right like i feel like
if ryan reynolds was the son he would
just be up there smiling and like hey
everyone i hope y'all are having a good
day
which would be awesome but i feel like
that would be ryan reynolds right so i'm
glad to see that he's kind of going
through and just maintaining all this
positivity and all this happiness and a
world that could otherwise be a little
chaotic and dark at times but moving on
to our next topic which is not the most
lighthearted of topics ever the russos
look like they're officially done with
marvel studios now i know a lot of you
guys are kind of like i mean didn't we
know that already not really we knew
that after the events of avengers
in-game in terms of them having like
multi-project films essentially that
they were kind of done right there
weren't really going to be any more like
captain america the winter soldier or
infinity war or avengers in-game type
projects coming the only thing we knew
is that at some future point in time
they seem to be on board for doing like
a secret wars movie but that was
basically it right they wouldn't really
be doing anything between now and then
but it seems like that in and of itself
is completely out the window now a lot
of this comes from a statement that was
made which reads its follows since the
lawsuit brothers joe russo and anthony
russo directors of marvel's avengers
in-game the highest grossing movie of
all time hit an impasse in negotiations
to direct another marvel movie the
johansen dispute left them unsure how
the next movie would be distributed and
how they would be paid according to
people familiar with the matter the
russos declined to comment now this was
reported to us so it's not really the
russo brothers directly giving us this
statement and so what this looks like is
it's not so much about the fact that
scarlett johansson was seemingly screwed
over by disney now the russos are pissed
and they're like we're not coming back
until you fix it it seems more of the
idea of what we expected in the
aftermath of scarlett johansson's
lawsuit which was the handling of the
release of black widow by disney plus in
relation to existing contracts with
talent and seemingly other members of
the movie production staff and the movie
production staff and talents concern on
whether those contracts will actually be
honored because truth to tell if disney
will screw over scarlett johansson
there's no reason to believe they won't
screw over the russos and that's the big
concern they have but having said that
let's kind of move into our discussion
about video games which i feel like is
what a lot of you guys
want us to talk about let's talk about
spider-man 2. now here's the funny thing
about this right when i saw the trailer
and they were like spider-man 2 and it's
going to have venom my thought was like
we already have spider-man 2 right it's
the miles wireless game i was like no
wait a minute that's not called
spider-man 2 miles morales it's just
called spider-man miles more else i like
that if i'm being honest with you guys i
like that right it's almost kind of like
an origin story video game for peter
parker and then an origin story video
game for miles morales and then they
meet in the middle with like a second
spider-man video game i guess
technically miles morales would be like
spider-man one and a half or almost kind
of like a dlc that was made into a full
video game i don't really know if i'm
being honest with you guys i think miles
morales was better than the original
spider-man game but having said that i'm
excited about this right insomniac games
does not miss and i am hyped when it
comes to the idea of them creating a new
spider-man game which features venom as
the main villain this is cool man you
know one thing that i've kind of been
thinking about in light of all this is
like so if if we're getting like a lot
of video games that are basically
including what would be fox properties
because the wolverine game is coming out
which we literally got nothing on that
outside of just like a giant bar fight
with wolverine sitting there somebody
walks in he pops his claws and the
trailer ends right so it's like a game
is coming that's basically what the
trailer was
more of a teaser than anything else but
with like video games being made really
as great as they are with what are fox
properties sony properties as far as the
movie rights are concerned going into
actual marvel properties this is
exciting man because it feels like it's
all kind of coalescing together here's a
crazy thought here right here's a crazy
idea what if in the king the conqueror
movie because i still stick by the idea
that the kane the conqueror film is
basically going to be avengers forever
right that's essentially what it's going
to be just avengers from different time
periods facing off against kang i think
it'd be the coolest thing ever but what
if all of that is basically kind of
coalescing from all this stuff that
we're seeing right so like the the sony
video game spider-man right because
technically he had his own comic book
line right he did have his own comic
book line for a little while and i think
you saw him in the new spider-verse
comic i don't remember because i don't
think i actually read that
new spider-verse comic
i had no desire to but regardless of the
situation would it be cool if like in
the kang movie you get like video game
characters who are brought in as part of
like this kind of avengers roster or
this superhero landscape they're facing
off against kang i know it sounds crazy
it probably won't happen but it seems
cool right because technically each one
of these video games is their own
universe although because insomniac is
making both the spider-man games and the
wolverine games i think it'd be cool if
they were in the same universe that
would be amazing so like you get like
spider-man 3 and like wolverine has like
a brief cameo or he's got like a cameo
and spider-man 2 that would be awesome i
would love to see that but regardless
it's a really exciting time and kind of
continuing our discussion here about
video games i got to be honest with you
guys it's the one thing i was the most
hyped about when it came from when it
came to the playstation oh my god the
playstation announcements is the one
thing i was the most excited about man
it's the one thing i didn't expect i've
been screaming about this forever i've
been screaming at this forever and ever
and ever and ever and then we're finally
getting it
kotor
remake yes oh my god let me tell you
something guys i loved the original
kotor game and i had no idea what i was
getting into when i got i had no idea
what i was getting into i remember
sitting at home and i was playing coach
or and then i was the dark side right of
course i was a doctor let me tell you
something those of you guys who have not
come from comments explain the one thing
that i have made perfectly clear on that
youtube channel is if i was gonna be a
comic book character i'd be a villain's
son i would man i'd be a bad guy like
absolutely man bad guys have more fun so
i'm sitting here at home and i'm playing
through co-tour my dad's watching me and
he's like why would you choose the dark
side and i was like because the dark
side's better like it's cool man it's
fun like like you guys like kotora had
so many great moments like that like
when you show up on tatooine and that
one chick has like her her husband's
hunter hunter plate or whatever it is
like the thing she's trying to sell to
make money and like i'm sitting there
going through all the options and like
this huge grin comes across my face and
i'm like my need is greater than yours
and i just take it from her like i just
take it away from her and then sell it
it's a terrible thing to do she
literally gets nothing right they're
left worse off than they were before but
i'm like dark side [ __ ] and just take
it leave it was terrible don't worry um
i made my karma whole i went back and
played to the light side and then let
her keep it and gave her money right i
was like whatever man like
you know but i am excited about this
those you guys who never played star
wars knight to the old republic the
reason why people are so excited about
this game is it was just it was landmark
at the time because the decisions that
you made over the course of the game
determined your alignment to the light
or the dark side and so you could
literally go through and you can make
decisions that would be dark side
choices and then make decisions that
would be light side choices and keep
yourself right in the middle where you
were neither light nor dark side but you
also got this kind of expansion that had
been established in a lot of different
ways but was basically a way for us to
kind of learn more about the star wars
mythos right xr [ __ ] who i believe i'm
pretty sure have been around for quite
some time as far as the star wars mythos
goes but he was the guy who invented a
double-bladed lightsaber but xr [ __ ] was
a really cool character he was not
really a part of the game more of the
mythos of the game the things that had
happened before the game started but
revan god revan is one of these
characters man i loved revan and i'm not
going to spoil the story for anybody who
hasn't played it but the story is
fantastic oh my god it's fantastic i
absolutely loved it star wars knights of
the old republic is one of the absolute
best video games ever created and i'm
not even saying like star wars video
games i mean one of the best video games
in general ever created
it was absolutely fantastic i loved it
and so i am incredibly hyped about kotor
the the remade game here's the funny
thing about this when it was first
released it was an xbox exclusive now
it's being re-released as a playstation
exclusive
right so you know it all kind of it did
a total 180 regardless like now i got to
get my hands on the ps5 i got a ps5 for
my girl i didn't really get one for
myself i've always been an xbox fan but
now i have to get a ps5 on the off
chance do they make a new uncharted game
they better god i'm so i really want to
see a new uncharted game they can follow
nathan drake's daughter if they want to
i don't really care but i want to see a
new uncharted game that was as good as
the other ones right i don't want to see
one that's rushed out and crappy i want
to see a good one but having said that
what we also got as far as video game
announcements we got to see some cool
stuff from god of war and it looks every
bit is awesome and i want to be honest
with you guys right i know this is going
to be a controversial opinion in
comparison or at least for a lot of god
of war fans out there
i think the newer games are better than
the older games like the storytelling
the way the game just feels and plays i
feel like it's better now a lot of god
of war fans i imagine might be mad about
that because in truth the new games play
differently than the old games the old
games were in a lot of ways kind of a
hack and slash game it had a great story
to it but it felt different than the
newer games but i like video games that
play like movies right they feel like
movies that's why i love the uncharted
series so much and so the the new god of
war games feel like i'm playing a movie
that also has gameplay in it having said
that thor from both the the character
mock-ups that we saw as well as at least
his hammer his hammer looks a lot
smaller than i thought it would but his
his hammer we got to see that in the in
the video game we got our first look at
tyr the son of odin let me tell you guys
something tear was legit it's t-y-r tyr
was amazing man this guy dude he was
like the bravest of all of odin's son
right like every god everywhere
respected this guy it was crazy truth to
tell like i know a lot of you guys are
coming from the comics in traditional
norse mythology thor was a dick right
like he was not nearly as heroic as he's
made out to be in the comics man he was
an [ __ ] so so tyr was was like the
guy right he was one of the coolest
characters in norwegian mythos
technically he's part of the acer saga
but nonetheless you know he's a really
really cool character i'm glad we got to
see him and i'm glad they kept up the
idea that he's every bit as enormous as
you would expect here to be but the game
looks great i'm still really excited to
see what's going to happen with loki
right i'm really excited because i don't
know if it's loki reborn i don't know if
it's loki who made himself into a kid
wiped his mind and kind of gave birth to
himself i have no idea right i mean i
know that seems weird but at the end of
the day fenris is a wolf that loki
basically had as like offspring there
was it's loki's done some weird stuff
over the course of the history of
norse mythology right so the idea of
loki giving birth to himself is not the
most unrealistic thing to happen
but having said that i'm excited about
it man the the great thing about the god
of war video games is the stories keep
me coming back because the stories look
more and more and more intriguing they
kind of take you down this rabbit hole
of mystery and so again i'm excited
about it right i'm very very hyped about
the new god of war game and having said
that our last little bit of news here
actually comes by way of the far cry
franchise now a lot of you guys know far
cry 6 is coming out it's got giancarlo
esposito which i'm really excited about
we have seen multiple gameplay trailers
of it they say it's in-game footage i
guess you won't really know until the
game comes out honestly it's for the ps5
i'm inclined to believe that it is
actually gameplay footage and not
cinematic stuff but regardless one of
the things that we're getting here is
actually a dlc expansion where you can
go through and control past villains
from the far cry franchise one of these
is vos the other one is like joseph seed
and pagan man honestly nobody cared
about them i think we can all
universally agree far cry 3 was the best
game right let's all let's all just nod
our heads and say yeah rob far cry 3 was
the best far cry game none of the far
cry games have been
that good ever since especially not four
five was okay but no threes were peaked
but the ability to control vos that
sounds cool because voss was he was such
an amazing villain did i ever tell you
what the definition of insanity is
i loved the character of vos he was so
amazing nonetheless right some dlc
that's coming later on down the line now
the big problem with this this is one of
the things that i hate about modern
video games they milk you for everything
you're worth right they nickel and dime
because in this day and age i feel like
aaa video games aren't necessarily made
for the enjoyment of the fan they're
made for the acquisition of wealth and
so that's why you have like games as a
service now different things like that
so these dlcs are going to cost you like
40 bucks and it'd be different if we
knew how long they were going to be
knowing ubisoft it's gonna be like four
hours of gameplay right and like three
of these so you're basically gonna get
12 hours of gameplay and they're gonna
charge a damn near top dollar for it i
don't know if that's actually gonna be
the case i imagine everybody in the
world is gonna be pissed off as it is
but in an age where companies like cd
projekt red are releasing games that
they knew were not anywhere close to
being finished i wouldn't be surprised
if a company like ubisoft gave us what
was in effect a kind of half-assed dlc
and charged this top dollar for it but
without being too much of a negative
nancy i am excited to see what it looks
like truth to tell i'm not going to buy
the dlc when it first comes out i'm
going to look at the reviews i'm going
to see what people say about the dlc and
then decide whether or not i think it's
worth it if i think it's worth it then
i'll buy it but if it's some dlc that
doesn't really amount to anyone any play
time or some kind of a horde mode
featuring vos then i just won't buy it
i'm gonna be like that's a waste i don't
want to buy that right and i'll just
i'll leave that at the door but having
said that i am excited about far cry 6.
the game looks like it's going to be
amazing the story looks like it's going
to be fantastic right i mean even if the
dlc kind of sucks the main far cry games
themselves have always been enjoyable
right that's the one thing that you
cannot dock ubisoft for when it comes to
the far cry franchise the games have
always been enjoyable i don't really
know anybody who sat down and played any
of the far cry games and walked away and
said these games as a whole suck these
games blow balls i mean the stories vary
from one game to the next and as i've
been saying far cry 3 had the best story
but the games themselves are enjoyable
right i mean far cry 5 was highly
immersive there was a lot more to do in
that game than there was in any of the
previous far cry games which makes sense
right i mean you always want to kind of
expand and build your games as time goes
on but regardless i'm looking forward to
what far cry 6 has to offer but with
that being said guys we're going gonna
bring this video to an end thank you
guys for watching this is our episode
for this week again it will stay on
sundays because it's really like an
undisturbed day and we will catch you
all later
peace